so we're told that silver oxide
decomposes according to the following
equation so for every two moles of
silver oxide it decomposes into four
moles of silver
and one mole of molecular oxygen
how many grams of silver oxide are
required to produce 1.5 0 liters of
oxygen gas at 1.22 atmospheres and 30
degrees celsius
so i want you to pause this video and
see if you can figure this out and i'll
give you a little bit of a hint
so you're used to saying oh well if i
know how many moles of oxygen i need to
produce then i need twice as many moles
of silver oxide because the ratio of
moles of silver oxide to molecular
oxygen is two to one
but they don't tell us how many moles of
molecular oxygen we're producing they
give us volume and pressure and
temperature but a little bit of a hint
is the ideal gas law it tells us that pv
is equal to n
r t and if we solve for n remember n is
just the number of moles so we divide
both sides by rt we get pv
over
rt
is equal to n
and it looks like they gave us all of
this stuff the pressure is right over
here the volume is right over here
the ideal gas constant we can look that
up and then temperature we just have to
convert this right over here into kelvin
and to help you there i will give you
some of the constants and the
conversions and so see if you can have a
go at this now
all right now let's work through this
together so the number of moles of
oxygen
is going to be equal to the pressure of
our oxygen so 1.22
atmospheres times the volume of oxygen
times
1.50 liters
divided by the ideal gas constant and we
have to use the right one that is going
to deal with atmospheres liters and
kelvin so if we're dealing with
atmospheres liters and kelvin then we'll
use this ideal gas constant right over
here so divided by 0.08
[Music]
i'll write the units here liters
atmospheres
divided by
moles
and also divided by
kelvin so this is our ideal gas constant
and then we're going to multiply that
times the temperature in kelvin now they
only gave us two significant figures
here they're only going to the ones
place so let's only only go to the ones
place when we convert to kelvin so let's
just add 273 to this so this is going to
be times
303
kelvin and let's make sure the units
work out that cancels with that that
cancels with that that cancels with that
and if we have a dividing by moles in
the denominator then that's just going
to become a moles eventually in the
numerator so this is going to be
approximately equal to
1.22 times 1.5 divided by
.08206
and then we're going to also divide that
whole thing by
303
is equal to this and let's see how many
significant figures we have 3
we have three
we have a lot more than three right over
here and then we have three right over
here so i'm going to round to three
significant figures so 0.0736
so
0.0736
moles
of molecular oxygen is how many we need
how much we need to produce to get this
volume at this pressure at this
temperature and so we're going to need
two times this
number of moles of silver oxide because
notice the two for every one mole of
molecular oxygen we produce we need
twice as many moles of silver oxide so
let's multiply this times two
so times two
gets us and once again three significant
figures
0.147 so this is approximately 0.14
moles
of silver
oxide that we need to produce but
they're not asking us how many moles of
silver oxide are needed they're asking
us how many grams so we just have to
multiply this times the molar mass so
let's first figure out the molar mass of
silver oxide i'll write it right over
here so silver
oxides molar mass is going to be
whatever the molar mass of silver is
times two
plus the molar mass of oxygen and so let
me get the periodic table of elements
out
molar mass of silver is 107.87
oxygen 16.00
so that gives us
107.87 for each of the silvers and then
plus
16.00 for the oxygen which gives us
107
times 2 is equal to that let's see it
goes to the hundredths place and then
plus
16.00 also goes to the hundreds place so
we'll go to
231.74 also going to the hundreds place
i'm just keeping track of the
significant figures when we're adding so
this is 231.74
grams per mole of silver oxide and so if
we take the moles of silver oxide and we
multiply that times 231.74
grams per mole and notice the moles
cancel out and we're just left with the
grams which is what we want this is
going to be approximately equal to and
we're going to end up with three
significant figures because we have
three here and five here
so we get we're going to take that and
multiply it by
.147
gives us this and three significant
figures would be 34.1
approximately
34.1 grams of
silver
oxide is required to produce this much
oxygen